whether you're working in healthcare or
not this information is so important to
know i've been asked in
multiple interviews for
different jobs or even my masters program
recruiters and health systems want
to know that you're up to date
on current events in healthcare
and how you get your news
i found this amazing website
that had the top eight major problems
in the us healthcare system
this included preventable medical errors
high mortality rates
lack of transparency
difficulty finding a doctor
high cost of care
lack of insurance coverage
nursing slash physician shortages
as well as inefficiencies
most of these are interconnected
so the biggest question is how
do we come to a solution
and as a healthcare professional it is up
to us to find solutions collaboratively
if you would like more information on this topic
check out medifind.com and
other related sources but if you
have a question that i can answer
or have any comments about this topic
please reply below in the comment section